IT’S ONE OF THE HARDEST WORKING
PEOPLE I KNOW IN CONGRESS, IT’S
CONGRESSMAN DOUG COLLINS
GEORGIA.
HE WAS THE RANKING MEMBER, BUT
NOW SINCE HE’S RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, BUT HE IS
JOINING US THIS MORNING, AND
WE’RE THRILLED TO HAVE HIM HERE.
AND, CONGRESSMAN, I WANT TO TELL
YOU, THE GOVERNMENT IS ASKING
POSTAL WORKERS TO GO TO WORK,
AND THEY’RE MANAGINGED TO DO IT.
BUT NANCY PELOSI DOESN’T SEEM TO
WANT CONGRESS TO GO BACK TO
WORK.
WHAT’S UP WITH THAT?
>> OH, JASON, YOU KNOW THIS, SHE
LIKES BEING IN CONTROL.
AS LONG AS SHE CAN KEEP US OUT
OF THERE, IT’S JUST LEADERSHIP
THAT MAKES DECISIONS.
WHEN SHE CAN CENTRALIZE
LEADERSHIP, THEN SHE CENTRALIZES
THE FOCUS ON HER INSTEAD OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, INSTEAD OF THE
AGENDA.
SPEAKER PELOSI HAS MADE THIS
MORE ABOUT HER AND HER AGENDA
THAN SHE HAS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT -- THE PRESIDENT’S
BEEN LEADING.
THE PRESIDENT’S LEADING FROM OUT
FRONT, HIM AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT, THEY’RE BEEN DOING
WHAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WE NEED TO COME BACK IN, BUT
SPEAKER PELOSI LIKES TO HOLD THE
CONTROL.
THAT’S WHAT IT SEEMS LIKE TO US
BECAUSE THERE’S NO REASON THE
HOUSE SHOULD NOT BE BEGINNING TO
COME BACK IN.
WE CAN MAKE THE ARRANGEMENTS, DO
WHAT WE NEED TO DO, BUT I
BELIEVE THIS IS ABOUT CONTROL.
WE’VE SEEN IT THROUGH
IMPEACHMENT, THROUGH MUELLER,
SHE LIKES TO HAVE CONTROL, AND
THIS IS WHAT THIS IS ALL ABOUT.
PETE: THE PRESIDENT GIVING HER
EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
HERE’S A JOINT STATEMENT, RAISED
AN EYEBROW FROM ME, FROM NANCY
PELOSI AND MITCH McCONNELL:
CONGRESS IS GRATEFUL FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION’S OFFER, BUT WE
RESPECTFULLY DELINE THE OFFER AT
THIS TIME.
OUR COUNTRY’S TESTING CAPACITIES
ARE CONTINUING TO SCALE UP, AND
CONGRESS WANTS TO KEEP DIRECTING
RESOURCES TO THE FRONT-LINE
FACILITIES.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED IN
RESPONSE TO THAT SAYING: NO
REASON TO TURN IT DOWN EXCEPT IF
POLITICS.
WE HAVE PLENTY OF TESTING.
CRAZY NANCY WILL USE IT AS AN
EXCUSE NOT TO SHOW UP TO WORK.
I’M NOT QUITE SURE WHY MITCH
McCONNELL SIGNED ON TO THAT
JOINT STATEMENT SINCE HE’S
OPENING UP THE SENATE, BUT IS
THERE ANY REASON?
YOU SAID CONTROL, AND IT’S
RIGHT, BUT THE NATION’S BUSINESS
IS SUPPOSED TO BE HAPPENING
HERE, AND SHE’S AWOL.
>> WELL, IT IS.
I MEAN, LOOK, WE CAN MAKE ALL
THE JOKES, AGAIN, IT’S ABOUT
CONTROL.
AND I THINK THIS IS THE CONCERN
FOR MOST OF US.
I’VE BEEN WORKING 24/7 IT SEEMS
LIKE FOR THE LAST LITTLE BIT ON
THE RESPONSE IF GEORGIA.
I’VE BEEN HAVING TO DO IT FROM
HOME, GOING TO MY OFFICE,
KEEPING SAFE, BUT IT’S TIME TO
START LOOKING AHEAD.
WHEN WE START LOOK AT NOT ONLY
THE RESPONSE THAT WE’VE HAD,
LET’S MAKE SURE WE CAN HAVE OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS, MAKE SURE
THE PROPER AID IS GOING WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE GOING.
WE’VE HAD PEOPLE NOT GETTING
AID, LET’S MAKE SURE WE’RE GOING
WHAT WE SHOULD WITH DOING IN
CONGRESS.
BUT WE’VE GOT TO LOOK FORWARD.
OUR COUNTRY IS REELING.
WE’VE GOT NATIONAL DEFENSE
AUTHORIZATION ACT, APPROPRIATION
BILLS, IT’S TIME TO SHOW
LEADERSHIP.
LEADERSHIP LEADS FROM THE FRONT,
NOT FROM THE BACK.
NANCY PELOSI NEEDS TO BRING THE
HOUSE BACK IN OR AT LEAST HAVE A
PLAN.
RIGHT NOW WE DON’T EVEN HAVE A
PLAN TO COME BACK IN.
JILLIAN: LET’S TALK ABOUT SOME
OF THESE STATES THAT ARE GOING
TO BE OPENING FINISH EASING
RESTRICTIONS, I SHOULD SAY.
ELEVEN STATES, AND, YOU KNOW,
GEORGIA’S BEEN THE TOPIC OF A
LOT OF CONVERSATION.
SOME BUSINESSES HAVE CHOSEN TO
OPEN, HERE’S A QUOTE FROM THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY: RESTAURANT
OWNERS UNDERSTAND THE SERIOUS
CHALLENGE AHEAD OF OUR INDUSTRY
AND OUR ENORMOUS RESPONSIBILITY
TO MANAGE THIS CRISIS
THOUGHTFULLY.
WE AGREE THAT IT’S IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF OUR EMPLOYEES, OUR
GUESTS, OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
INDUSTRY TO KEEP OUR DINING
ROOMS CLOSED AT THIS TIME,
RECOGNIZING THAT EACH OPERATOR
FACES INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ON THE PATH AHEAD, WE
AFFIRM THE FACT THAT PUBLIC
SAFETY IS THE TOP PRIOR THE CITY
AS WE NAVIGATE THE CHALLENGE.
YOU KNOW, SIR, AT LEAST THEY
HAVE THE CHOICE TO BE ABLE TO
REOPEN IF THEY WANT, BUT SOME
PEOPLE ARE CHOOSING NOT TO.
THAT’S THEIR DECISION, BUT OTHER
STATES DON’T HAVE THE CHOICE
RIGHT NOW.
>> REPORT IN.
I MEAN, THE -- THAT’S RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE IT CLEAR.
WITH THE GUIDELINES THAT ARE
THERE, WE NEED TO FOLLOW WHAT
THE TAX FORCE HAS SAID.
BUT AS WE DO SO LIKE HERE IN
GEORGIA, THOSE THAT WANT TO OPEN
BACK, HAVE THAT ABILITY.
WE’VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND THIS
VIRUS DID NOT AFFECT EVERY STATE
THE SAME WAY AND NOT EVEN INSIDE
THE STATE THE SAME WAY.
AND THERE’S GOT TO BE
FLEXIBILITY FOR THOSE PLACES
THAT WERE NOT HIT AS HEAVY THAT
THEY CAN OPEN BACK UP TO NOT
JUST BLANKETLY -- IT’S LIKE
PUNISHING THE WHOLE CLASS WHEN
ONLY ONE PERSON WAS DOING
SOMETHING WRONG.
LOCAL INVOLVEMENT IS IMPORTANT,
AND THAT’S WHY WE’RE SEEING
BUSINESSES BE ABLE TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE.
IT’S TIME WE START LOOKING AT
THE HEALTH BENEFITS BUT ALSO THE
ECONOMIC CRISIS AND MAKE SURE WE
MOVE FORWARD SO THAT PEOPLE HAVE
CHOICES, AND THEY CAN MAKE THOSE
CHOICES.
IT’S ALWAYS BEEN MUCH BETTER
THAN GOVERNMENT MAKING THOSE
CHOICES FOR THEM.
JASON: YEAHING CONGRESSMAN, I
THINK YOU’RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IF A BUSINESS CHOOSES NOT TO
OPEN, THAT’S THEIR RIGHT AS
WELL.
IN THE LITTLE TIME WE HAVE LEFT,
I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON THIS
GENERAL FLYNN SITUATION.
THERE’S THIS DEEP CONCERN, YOU
AND I PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN THIS ABOUT THE UPPER
ECHELON OF THE FBI.
I WORRY THAT IT HAS NOT BEEN
CLEANED UP.
BUT THE REVELATION OF THESE NEW
DOCUMENTS AND NEW NOTES ABOUT
THE INTENT AND THE PLANNING, THE
AMBUSH, IF YOU WILL, THAT
HAPPENED WITH GENERAL FLYNN
THERE IN THE WHITE HOUSE, WHAT’S
YOUR TAKE ON THAT, AND WHERE DO
YOU SEE THAT GOING NEXT?
>> JASON, GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT
UP BECAUSE YOU AND I, MANY
OTHERS HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT
THIS.
WE KNOW THIS WAS GOING ON.
WE COULD TELL THROUGH THE
DOCUMENTS, WE KNEW IF WE COULD
CONTINUE TO FIND OUT, WE COULD
SEE THE CORRUPT CABAL OVER THERE
OF COMB AND McCABE, STRZOK AND
PAGE, JIM COMEY USED -- AND HE
SAID IT -- USED THE FIRST WEEKS
OF THE ADMINISTRATION TO ATTACK
BASICALLY THIS PRESIDENT.
HE’D ALREADY BEEN DOING IT
THROUGH THE CANDIDACY.
IT SHOWS THAT HE WANTS TO PLAY
SUPERMAN, AND IT’S A SHAME.
I WANT TO REMIND PEOPLE, IF THEY
CAN DO THIS TO GENERAL FLYNN,
THEY CAN DO IT TO ANYBODY.
ANDREW McCABE WAS ONE THAT
ACTUALLY APPROVED, THIS HE LIED
TO HIS OWN COLLEAGUES, WAS NOT
CHARGED.
HE WAS FIRED BUT NEVER CHARGED.
AND YET THEY CHARGED GENERAL
FLYNN WITH LYING.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN AN
ATTACK ON A CANDIDATE AND THEN
ON A SITTING PRESIDENT.
THAT’S WHY THIS HAS TO BE
INVESTIGATED, HAS TO STOP.
PETE: WELL, THERE IS AN
INVESTIGATION ONGOING.
THE PRESIDENT REFERRED TO IT
YESTERDAY IN A TWEET.
HE SAID THE RUSSIA HOAX THE
BIGGEST POLITICAL SCANDAL IN
HISTORY.
TREASON.
LET’S SEE HOW THIS ENDS,
QUESTION MARK.
YOU’VE GOT BILL BARR, YOU’VE GOT
DURHAM DOING THIS INVESTIGATION,
AND REPORTS ARE THEY’VE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION REGULARLY.
WHERE DOES THIS END?
>> BILL BARR APPOINTED ANOTHER
U.S. ATTORNEY, JENSEN, TO
ACTUALLY LOOK INTO THIS FLYNN
CASE, AND I THINK THAT’S WHY
YOU’RE SEEING MOVEMENT NOW.
BUT WHEN YOU SEE NOTES WHERE
THEY WERE ACTIVELY TARGETING
GENERAL FLYNN, ACTIVELY
SUBVERTING THE RULES AND
PROTOCOLS, I THINK DURHAMING IS
BUILDING A CASE.
HE’S GOT ACCESS TO EVERYTHING HE
NEEDS, AND IT’S ALSO WHY YOU’LL
SEE THE CABAL SCURRYING AROUND,
BECAUSE THEY’RE SCARED.
I THINK WE’RE GOING TO SEE
ACCOUNTABILITY.
THAT’S WHAT WE’VE ALL WANTED
FROM DAY ONE, AND IT’S TIME TO
DO.
THAT’S YOU SHOULD NEVER BE ABLE
TO ATTACK A CANDIDATE FOR
PRESIDENT JUST BECAUSE YOU DON’T
LIKE HIM TO HAVE INSURANCE
POLICIES OR WHATEVER ELSE YOU
WANT.
YOU CAN’T USE THE FISA COURT AND
THE METHODS AT YOUR ABILITY.
IF THEY CAN DO IT TO A CANDIDATE
AND A PRESIDENT, THEY CAN DO IT
TO YOU AND ME.
JILLIAN: AND I THINK IT’S HARD
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO LOOK AT
THE HEADLINES AND SEE ALL THE
BACK AND FORTH.
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE THEN WHO
MIGHT LOSE FAITH IN, YOU KNOW,
OUR OFFICIALS THAT NOW MORE THAN
EVER IT’S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE.
THAT’S.
>> OH, VERY MUCH SO.
LOOK, WE ALL SERVE IN THE PUBLIC
TRUST, OR BEING OUT THERE AND
MAKING SURE WE’RE BEING
ACCOUNTABLE TO PEOPLE.
YOU CAN’T BE IN A POSITION AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE -- THE
OBAMA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
BECOME A POLITICAL HAVEN AT THE
TOP ESPECIALLY.
WE SAW THAT WITH THE CLINTON
E-MAIL SITUATION, WITH THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION AND THEN WE
SAW IT MANIFOLD ITSELF INTO THE
IMPEACHMENT SAGA.
SO THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT’S
GOING ON AND PEOPLE DON’T NEED
TO FORGET IT BECAUSE THE
BUREAUCRATS WANT YOU TO FORGET
IT, AND THIS CORRUPT CABAL WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU TO FORGET IT.
PETE: VERY MUCH.
REAL QUICK, WE ONLY HAVE A
MOMENT LEFT, YOU’RE GOING FOR
THE U.S. SENATE IN GEORGIA, GIVE
US AN UPDATE.
>> THE PEOPLE HAVE RESPONDED
WELL.
THEY KNOW ME, THEY KNOW THAT
I’LL FIGHT FOR THIS PRESIDENT,
THIS COUNTRY AND THE
CONSERVATIVE MATTERS.
WE’RE LEADING IN THE POLLS BY A
LARGE MARGIN, BUT WE’RE NOT
GOING TO STOP.
WE’RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CARRYING THIS FIGHT, CONTINUING
WITH THE PRESIDENT FOUR MORE
YEARS.
PETE: REPRESENTATIVE, THANK YOU